has to be on a it has to be on a smaller
side of the spectrum
it has to be on the smaller side
how low from the from that i'm just
curious would you consider a girl high
value how many bodies there's too many
bodies
according to that's the man according to
rollo tomasi if you've got more than
five then
you've lost it so
so five or more yeah okay what about you
all right
how many bodies is too high
yeah a high value
yeah no it's got to be five or less i
can't add five or less what how go ahead
let's go
i i can't answer this because i don't
think the high value women as a
statement really exists unless she's got
a ring chosen right but hypothetically
yeah not exactly but then
it's disingenuous because like oh it's
just a fun question
i like your idea
as a high value woman
yeah i'd say five is a fair number i
would say at what age though like oh
20 21 i think she's 27. based off what
pearl says she's 27. she's probably got
more than that yeah wait wait i'll argue
that that case actually it's more so
that high value is the idea that you can
secure a man and be in a relationship
like so like if someone's having
long-term relationships maybe two three
years
by the time they're 27 if they started
dating at
let's say 18 they would have had three
bodies
and that in itself would be like a man
has seen you and he thought i need to
secure this
maybe it hasn't worked out but you've
shown
thank you of the results to show you the
results and those guys they have to be
high value
yeah but then you don't also think that
potentially that's also a red flag
because that means typically women end
relationships
so like then is she is she high value if
she keeps leaving
yeah
she's not that's right because like
wouldn't that if she got three
high-value men she couldn't pick one she
liked yeah that's that would that be a
lack of loyalty i don't think i don't
think i'm just i don't i don't feel
strongly about this either way i don't
think girls leave high value men like
that
like i don't think girls leave the
alphas like that it's a little bit
harder yeah i think it's hard to because
because a alpha guy will cheat on a girl
and she'll come back
there has to be something
lacking
either mentally or emotionally for them
to in my opinion for women to leave a
high value man because he's going to
provide for them security is not a
problem but if there is a lack
in those feminine traits that
we essentially
need from a man then she may not cheat
right away but i think mentally yeah
i think it's hypergamy though i think a
lot of girls that are eights nines and
tens are for the streets forever because
they just have so many high value men
interested in them they can't pick
interesting and they can't go down evil
sorry no no good they can't they can't
go down in it because of high school so
if a girl's 22 right and at 22 she
really like she's eight nine or ten that
means about the time she's 22 she's
getting guys with blue check marks in
her dms if she's if she's hot enough
right yeah and so she sleeps with one at
22 dates him for two years let's just
say but then she thinks she can do
better and she keeps thinking she can do
better and maybe she does until one day
she can't do better and then she's for
the streets forever because women can't
go back down and be happy about it and
the women that do let's say kim
kardashian right
okay what the human knowledge yeah they
leave them
or or they have their husband by the
yeah and i mean sometimes sometimes like
it depends how like the girl has to see
the guy is better like it's not
necessarily income like i've heard i've
heard nicki minaj's husband is like very
masculine and holds frank that's just
something i've heard don't know if it's
true don't know anything about nicki
minaj
[Music]
a bird apparently and then you come out
and then
when he's out she's come back to him
he wait say it again riding a bird he
was in prison oh yeah
i thought you were talking about this
that's for the audience no sorry my bad
he was in prison he had he had one
prison sentence he was inside jail and
whatnot youtube when he's come back out
she was saying i think they've gone back
together in it but they were old like
old school sweethearts type of thing
apparently that was the situation if i
remember correctly so yeah
but i think she was but he obviously i
think he come out making less than
less than her and whatnot but well who's
going to make more than nicki minaj yeah
not that many
yeah
yeah not to be fair would you consider
women athletes high value no
if they're chosen by a high value man
yes
so only if they're chosen by a high
value man
so essentially
i could be
a bum but super
good looking and get chosen by a high
value man and then be considered high
value yeah exactly
exactly there we go
that's the gift i think that's the gift
that was given to
i think that's the gift that was given
to women in it because obviously i think
this world is hard in it like the world
is hard and people struggle to
understand and i think i think god
favored women in a bit because it gave
them that gift of beauty a lot of women
are beautiful there's loads and loads of
beautiful women in the world do you
understand so it's like it almost gives
you an out obviously
guys you have to work for what you get
to understand you have to work for what
you get whatever you get you have to
work for it nothing's going to come easy
for you and once you've got that that's
when you deserve you know you know you
reap what you sold it
you deserve whatever you sold women
women are born with value men must earn
their value yeah oh wow it's explained
so women when a woman's born she she is
the most valuable asset
like so so a girl can be 18 and get
multi-million dollar modeling contracts
she could she could do only fans make
millions like she is a valuable asset
beauty is currency that's why you see at
um political protest women always take
off their clothes because that's the
best way to get attention is a beautiful
woman
and men
there there's a large proportion of men
that are invisible under the age of like
25. and but if they focus on money
muscles frame and game by the time
they're 35
they can get girls left and right
like jeff bezos right yeah i mean that's
not i don't know what he's doing with
that one [ __ ] but
yeah that's the perfect example because
no one is looking twice at jeff bezos
when he's 18. but you know now he's
built up to be a billionaire he's got he
can screw whoever he wants still ain't
looking at him he got money but
given him giving you 50 grand will be
let him get like 50p yeah
literally and it's like toilet paper but
let's say let's say hallie halle berry
you don't really hear about her she's
she's still pretty but she's not she's
not the guy girl that guys are lined up
for anymore nope yeah margot robbie
what's your favorite even um
steve harvey's daughter
i mean i know she's for the streets but
in terms of attention she gets so much
attention
but it goes away when you lose your
looks yeah and she's kind of and she's
kind of announced herself that she's
full of streets when she kind of yeah
said no to michael b jordan in it
he kind of wanted to propose to her and
take her seriously which would have
elevated her to
high value
you understand but and and the other
thing is that a girl should like she can
be 18 and marry a billionaire but like
no guy can do that
yeah no
and so i don't think a lot of times
girls we don't realize how much how
different we're treated because we're
young women
like you're automatically like more
people hold the door for you more people
are nicer to you more like men give you
attention just because you're you know
under the age of 30.
do you think is different
across um
different ethnicities and races like how
um
i guess you see how men like view women
like is there like a superior type of
woman to like an inferior type of woman
i think hot is hot yeah yeah
i don't think there's anything margo
robbie and i know lori harvey's for the
streets but she's beautiful they both
get a ton of attention
they're both stunning i don't think men
are i think you can drop you can drop
that laurie harvey anywhere in the world
and they'll think she's beautiful she
understands like she don't think she's
beautiful but um
what what what's next what kind of
different is the culture and what a
culture would consider um high value is
she a wife do
is she a wife like how does she carry
her how does she carry herself
that's what that's where it differs
isn't it yeah but it's like what men are
asking women to do isn't necessarily
hard fit feminine friendly
what women ask men to do is hard
six inches six figures six feet they
can't grow
they need surgery now and they're yeah
that's a lot of guys proud i don't think
the guys probably can't do that well i i
say that like you can't just well people
be injecting their knees and what no
point installing um
plates inside their knees just so they
can grow but realistically i think most
guys proud wouldn't allow them to just
just get surgery just so they can grow
like most guys wallets wouldn't allow
them to grow if they had the option to
tell them
you can grow like two feet and it was
legit you think they're not taking it
and also mango but
are you not taking it